it is a grand display of power thousands
of Chinese leaders in one place to set
the path of the Republic but the
ceremonial pompeia comes amid growing
gloom about the country's economic
fortunes among the foot soldiers feeling
the fallout this Beijing sock
manufacturer just two of its 12 weaving
machines are in operation the boss
blames the trade dispute with Washington
some of our US clients have already
moved their orders to Southeast Asia
where the labor costs are lower than
here it's had a big impact on us the
impact will get worse if the trade war
between China and the US escalates
especially in the number of orders which
will greatly affect us there is mounting
pressure on Chinese and US negotiators
to settle that tariff war economic
slowdown saw growth in 2018 at its
lowest in three decades
brought on by internal and external
forces if a man could coordinate in
colonia on the one hand china has an
aging population problem and our
traditional industries are suffering
downward pressures on the other hand the
traditional export oriented economy is
facing extrusion their annual gathering
in Beijing delegates are expected to
rubber-stamp a series of policies aimed
at addressing US trade concerns embed to
try to left the mood all right China of
course a huge and very important market
also for German exporters so let's bring
in early Birds our financial
correspondent in Frankfurt to learn a
little bit more about this reports that
the United States and China could be
close to a deal what's - that well I
think it's a very plausible story there
in the Wall Street Journal we just heard
about the pressures the economic ones in
China and they're closely related to the
political worries that the of the people
at the top the People's Congress will
begin this week and you have similar
pressures in the United States
a different nature but there the economy
is also slowing down in the huge tax
breaks that Donald Trump for example
gave business and consumers while
they're wearing out this year and 2020
could be a year of recession and in the
election year basically both sides needs
a deal that improves the economic
situation they're not worse in it all
right only but they're reporting for us
from Frankfurt thank you so much
you